[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau rendez vous du 7 8
sociétés votre magazine où l'on discute
des sujets qui font l'actualité à leur
facteur favorisant ou responsables de
cancer il est considéré que plus de 30%
de l'ensemble des cancers dépend du
tabac la ligue contre le cancer souhaite
des morales y ait débat excusez moi
j'aime bien le mot souhaitait réduire le
tabagisme et protéger les plus jeunes
plus de 3700 espace sans tabac sont
répartis à travers la france dé commune
yvelinoise y adhèrent petit à petit
faut-il interdire la cigarette en
extérieur on en parle avec nos invités
maurice brun bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
président du comité des yvelines de la
ligue contre le cancer et cédric cédric
bemba marine bonsoir bonsoir êtes le
maire du port marly
maurice brun avant de développer plus
longuement cette émission est ce que
vous vous pouvez nous présenter ces
espaces en tas va justement oui alors
c'est une c'est une campagne qui a lancé
la ligue il ya une grosse dizaine
d'années en à peu près et qui a fleuri
assez abondamment il y a même des
endroits où il ya effectivement dans
come as tu as vu 200 espaces un tabac
dans la même ville il y en a un nombre
considérable également à paris et nous
en yvelines un petit peu en retard
dillon qu'effectivement on avait un
petit peu négligé cette campagne parce
que je n'aime pas trop qu'on associe la
ligue avec des interdictions ont déjà
qu'on est déjà pas mal donneurs de
leçons avec vous pas fumer faut pas
boire d'alcool qui taxera rajouter une
interdiction ça ne paraissait pas tout à
fait c'est ans néanmoins les choses
étant ce qu'elles sont et le risque de
tabac puisque le tabasse notre plus gros
nbi à la ligue eh bien on a nous même
lancée c'est un certain nombre de deux
questionnaires 6 jeudi auprès des maires
de l'ensemble des communes des yvelines
et effectivement nous avons eu une bonne
quinzaine de réponses favorables et
d'ores et déjà nous avons contient une
poignée ennemi c'est aux dires de deux
municipalités qui ont accepté de
fonctionner et de est de faire en sorte
que une convention soit signée et
d'autres vont tenir certainement alors
en 2012 c'est nice alors pas chez nous
mais c'est nice qui inaugure ses espaces
sans tabac c'est sur les plages plus
précisément dans les yvelines c'est
bonnet la première à adopter cette
convention c'était en 2019 plus
récemment il ya aussi fontenay-le-fleury
elle a fait le choix de le mettre en
place regarder
un nouvel affichage va arriver près des
aires de jeux d'ici quelques jours il ne
sera plus possible de fumer près désert
pour enfants fontenay-le-fleury
s'associe avec la ligue contre le cancer
pour mettre en place des espaces sans
tabac c'était dans le cadre du plan
santé de la ville et puis c'était aussi
puisque tous ces endroits des espaces
publics où l'on va installer des
panneaux n'était pas protégée en fait
par la loi contre le tabac donc
on s'est dit que déjà pour éviter que
les jeunes s'initient au tabac protéger
l'environnement des mégots de cigarettes
et puis réduire le tabagisme passif de
la prévention avant la mise en place de
sanctions le non respect de ces espaces
entraînera une amende de 38 euros quinze
lieux seront concernés dont les huit
établissements scolaires de la commune
je pense que c'est une bonne chose déjà
deux d'éloigner les enfants
tout ce qui peut être
fumé de cigarette les odeurs les
habitudes aussi c'est jamais évident
parce qu'il ya des habitudes ont été
prises et donc
c'est faire changer les habitudes c'est
faire changer ce que les adultes peuvent
nous proposer j'ai 29 ans j'ai toujours
eu des gens qu'on fume et je ne suis pas
morte pour autant que moi je pars du
principe que si on a fumé on fumera moi
j'étais grosse fumeuse à l'époque parce
qu'effectivement j'ai bas j'ai pas eu de
ma mère n'a jamais fumé j'ai fait comme
les autres à l'école ou au collège plus
exactement j'ai commencé j'avais 12 ans
d'autres lieux pourrait devenir des
espaces sans tabac sur la commune comme
les gymnases et le collège 30% de
l'ensemble des cancers dépendent du
tabac alors fontenay le fleury a voté
tout cela le 30 septembre lors du
dernier conseil municipal cédric pin
marine au port marly le conseil
municipal huile a voté en mai pourquoi
absolument mais il a voté en mai parce
que très très sensible à la démarche
portée par la ligue contre le cancer et
ses représentants qui sont venus nous
présenter à moi ainsi qu'à mon adjointe
en charge des questions de société
solidarité un peu le hip de ces espèces
sans tabac je crois que c'est assez ça
peut être ça peut être l'occasion
d'autres sujets mais c'est un sujet qui
a fait l'unanimité l'équipe qui
m'entoure dire que l'ensemble des des
adjoints qui m'entourent ont été
séduits par cette démarche et donc il a
été décidé de la proposer
à l'ensemble du conseil municipal en mai
et senna c'est une délibération qui
étaient adoptés à l'unanimité
oui justement qu'est ce qui a séduit
l'équipe municipale dans cette
convention total à la démarche nous est
paru particulièrement intéressante déjà
une idée de se dire que
ni à la loi qui a prévoit déjà certaine
mesure et pour les mesures qui ne sont
pas prévues par la loi s'ils n'ont pas
accompagné à travers une démarche qui se
veut avant tout pédagogique
vraiment c'est une démarche citoyenne
c'est inciter les parents à ne pas
donner pour exemple aux enfants à la
sortie des lieux qu'ils fréquentent le
le plus souvent c'est à dire l'école ou
les parcs de jeux ne pas leur donner
pour exemple 2 1 par an c'est quelqu'un
qui chemin en attendant son enfance et
sa muse a paru être une démarche
honorable et qu'on avait à coeur de
déployer sur la commune maurice bras on
l'a entendue dans le reportage et une
mère de famille qui dit oui au final on
interdit tout est-ce que c'est aussi
quelque chose qui vous inquiétez c'est
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure oui
tout à fait bon c'est jamais très
amusant d'être
taxé de systématiquement interdiction
préconisations on passe pour des
donneurs de leçons c'est celle et que
qu'il faut éviter néanmoins néanmoins si
on doit revenir sur quelque chose de
véritablement pratique c'est le tabac
c'est notre pire ennemi c'est clair
l'alcool le tabac bien évidemment sont
les deux
facteurs principaux mais si vous voulez
le tabac véritablement n'apportant rien
et donc si vous voulez
c'est pour nous actuellement un objectif
prioritaire d'arriver à faire en sorte
que les gens puissent se passer du tabac
on a proposé nous mêmes dans l'autre au
comité des séances de indique nos anti
tabac par exemple donc pau filière ont
montré aussi qu'on ne fait pas qu
interdire non pas des solutions mais
c'est vrai qu effectivement c'est assez
terrible et je dois vous dire simplement
que dans les deux ans on s'attend à ce
que le nombre de femmes décédées d'un
cancer du poumon dépasse celui des
cancers du sein c'est un cancer terrible
qui fait beaucoup souffrir qui est un
taux tune est assez c'est vraiment ses
négatifs et si vous voulez pour nous
c'est l'ennemi numéro un donc si vous
voulez toutes les armes sont bonnes même
si même si dans ces cas là effectivement
on se répète et on va jusqu'à on va
jusqu'à l'interdiction elle s'adresse
cédric mamba marine est ce que vous
aussi vous avez eu des retours enfin
quel retour avez justement de vos
administrés sur cette décision
allait les retours sont plutôt sont
plutôt positifs les parents comprennent
les mardis porta sont pas à moi civique
que les autres bien au contraire et
c'est pour ça que on avait peu de doute
sur le fait que cette
mesure là soit acceptée et comprise
comprise de plus j'entends ce qui est
intéressant dans le reportage que vous
avez bien voulu diffuser ces personnes
nues dit à la fois ces nouvelles
interdictions dit si on doit être
fumeurs on le sera mais elle finit par
dire j'ai fait comme tous mes camarades
effectivement c'est là la question c'est
avant quel exemple on donne et si on
arrive à casser cette chaîne exemple is
dénormaliser d'utilisation du tabac je
pense qu'on a tous à y gagner
ça c'est un sujet de santé publique
important mais c'est ça monsieur brun
ont souvent quand on en vient à fumer
c'est pour faire comme les autres
pour les jeunes oui effectivement il ya
ces modèles on est rabattue de modèles
que ce soit dans les médias dans le ciné
max théret sinon c'est un image de
virilité de l'affirmation de soi qui est
complètement dont à battre en brèche une
certaine manière et c'est vrai que c'est
malheureux que les enfants soient très
sensible ces signaux cédric pemba marine
la ville de fontenay envisage plus tard
d'agrandir ses espaces est ce que vous
aussi au port-marly vous envisager
d'autres secteurs et se passe sans tabac
ou pour le moment vous allez voir
comment la ville réagit c'est exactement
ça alors si j'avais dû suivre
complètement l'engouement
de ce qui m'entoure il y aurait plus de
dieu que ça pour lesquels l'interdiction
du tabac aurait pété égalité l'idée
c'est de voir dans un premier temps
comment ça se passe de d'être déjà en
mesure de faire respecter cette règle là
et puis après on verra cinq gardiens pas
de revoir les lieux sur lesquels une
interdiction de fumer est prévue
nous suivrons aussi
le tabac est la première cause de cancer
qu'on peut éviter en fait oui
complètement samedi en tête de liste
c'est clair c'est vrai on parle souvent
de l'alcool et le tabac bon l'alcool
peut supporter célia des événements
festifs et à la gastronomie on les paie
de la bonne chère et du bonze c'est plus
difficile à accepter de battre en brèche
évidement un problème de l'alcoolisation
de la population mais pour le tabac
vient tellement quels sont les avantages
qui peut me dire véritablement qu'ils
tirent avantage de sa consommation de
tabac sur d'être extrêmement et c'est
pour ça que pour nous c'est
véritablement le pire ennemi et leurs
voeux je voudrais simplement ajouter une
chose c'est que les hommes ont largement
fléchi leur consommation de cigarettes
ce qui fait la courbe des décès par
cancer du poumon chez les hommes a très
largement fléchi il ya déjà de
nombreuses années mais chez les femmes
c'est en constante augmentation et en
conscience et c'est une procuration
extraordinaire pour nous c'est un clin
d'oeil à mme harel on a parlé du
mimétisme est aussi quelque chose de
très important c'est le tabagisme passif
on a boat dehors et quand on est proche
d'un fumeur n'est amené à respirer ça
fume et ses espaces sans tabac vont
pouvoir aussi
réduire ce tout cela absolument c'est
une manière de réduire l'exposition de
nos jeunes au fumée de tabac alors
certes c'est certainement un phénomène
beaucoup moins impactant que dans les
milieux fermés pour lesquels la le
législateur a déjà prononcé
l'interdiction beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus large était important ou de
poursuivre d'étendre cette protection
finalement offerte publics les plus
fragiles aux lieux qu'ils fréquentent tu
fréquentes en masse parfois de manière
très statique parce que voilà un entrées
et sorties d'écoles notamment donc
c'était important de pouvoir protéger
nos jeunes jeunes citoyens le chan mardi
portant alors parlé de cette parents
d'élèves qui étaient quand j'ai
rencontré de ses parents c'était avant
la seule aide sur ces espaces en tabac
et puis on voit que ça évolue la loi la
loi evin à 30 ans elle interdisait de
fumer dans les locaux à usage collectif
depuis le 1er février 2007 il est
interdit de fumer dans tous les lieux
fermés couvert accueillant du public ou
qui constitue le lieu de travail
talisman de santé encore être en ce
moment est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer
plus tard une ville 100 % sans tabac
alors là je
veux pas vous le dire c'était c'est très
difficile d'imaginer je pense qu'il ya
comme une certaine limite à la la
liberté individuelle qui fait que
véritablement on ne pourra certainement
pas interdire mais je pense qu'il n'est
pas exclu que certaines villes dans
certains pays un peu extrémiste si je
veux dire à jusque-là pourquoi pas
monsieur pas ma marraine justement est
ce qu'un jour vous pensez pouvoir
arriver à cette décision justement il
faut pas tout interdire
je crois que ozon forme et se veulent à
une ville sans fumeurs au renom de
plaisent à certains dont c'est
l'activité je peux comprendre que sur
une mesure qui puisse rencontrer
quelques réticences mais mais on ne vit
pas par l'interdiction et c'est clair
pas par l'interdiction par la pédagogie
et là ce sera un véritable succès une
interdiction sur 100 pour cent je crois
qu'il ya effectivement
ce serait ce serait une atteinte attente
disproportionnée quand bien même la
l'enjeu encore une fois en terme de
santé publique et est important ce
serait difficilement acceptable et nous
pour que ce soit respectée il faut que
la mesure soit acceptable
de pédagogie justement monsieur mana est
ce que dans la commune avant même les
sanctions se fontenay le fleury mettra
une annonce ce sera une amende de 38
euros s qui a eu la pédagogie au
port-marly est-ce qu'il y en a toujours
alors chez nous c'est encore en cours de
déploiement et donc la consigne qui a
été donné la consigne est claire
l'objectif c'est vraiment pas d'aller
verbaliser
les habitants c'est vraiment d'y aller
en accompagnement et je crois que c'est
un phénomène
c'est vraiment un phénomène de groupe je
pense que si c'est accepté par une
majorité
ça se fera
ça se fera sans heurts sans difficulté
chacun comprendra s'il devait y avoir
des récalcitrants
qui ne respectent pas de manière
de manière répétée cette interdiction
n'a devra passer à des mesures un peu
plus dur et je crois pas qu'on doive est
on arrivé ici au programme les bras vous
le disiez tout à l'heure il n'y a pas
encore beaucoup de communes être une
dizaine dans les yvelines être favorable
à cette décision est ce que vous sentez
encore des réticences vous devez
argumenté ou au contraire les communes
que vous avez communiqué rentrer très
vite dans discussions avec vous sur
cette convention jeu parce que celles
qui ne se sont pas encore décidé qui
nous ont contactés néanmoins suite à
notre démarche c'est simplement une
question technique ils n'ont pas encore
mis 7 à l'ordre du jour d'un conseil
municipal ou n'ont pas encore voté ou
extra mais je veux dire qu'effectivement
c'est une question l'ade et les
techniques tout simplement de
l'application je ne pense pas que les
interlocuteurs con et tu es tu as envie
de faire marche arrière si vous voulez
maintenant il reste il reste encore un
nombre considérable dans les yvelines et
on n'est pas au bout de nos peines
néanmoins mais disons qu effectivement
avec cette poignée ennemis de 2,2
municipalité on espère justement
effectivement faire un petit peu 1 1 à
nice marquants de la préoccupation de la
sa tombe des nues vous les accompagnez
commencé comme une bombe à disons que ce
sont des contacts ciblés
nous avons vocation à être sur tout le
territoire des yvelines par les actions
qu'on fait dans les écoles par les
actions qu'on fait à droite à gauche
avec les municipalités pour différents
différentes manifestions et autres donc
si vous voulez on est présent tout au
long de l'année auprès de la population
que ça soit qu'ils ne soient pas donc si
vous voulez partir du moment que l'on
rend ton en discussion avec une
musicalité pour un espace sans tabac ils
nous connaissent déjà un petit peu par
ailleurs ils ont déjà si j'ose dire un
certain nombre de leurs personnes de
leurs populations qui sont donateurs
chez nous ou qui bénéficient nous sommes
support ou qui bénéficient de nos z
financière qui est extra ou nous actions
dans les écoles et par exemple on
distribue 16000 agenda scolaire tous les
ans donc dans un pub sans commune sans
commune des yvelines dont il voulait
déjà si vous voulez on a apprécié le
territoire depuis de nombreuses années
on a beaucoup parlé du volet santé et
qui est l'un des plus importants liés au
tabac ya aussi l'aspect environnemental
puisque chaque année et estimé qu'en
france entre 20000 et 25000 tonnes de
quantité de mégots sont jetés cédric
même d'un aréna est ce que c'est un
frein que vous rencontrez aussi sur
votre commune
j'ai juste avant si vous permettre
justement répondre à cette question là
je vais veiller à ce que vient de dire
non seulement moi je crois ce phénomène
vertueux et est-ce qu'on fait l'exercice
combien ce soir comme les airs sic a été
menée
et quelques temps par d'autres médias
qui ont repris un peu d'initiatives qui
était porté au port marly et qui
visiblement est porté déjà ailleurs le
fait de la rendre de l'enfer la
publicité ça participera à ce qu'elle
puisse s'étendre à d'autres comme moi
j'ai déjà d'autres collègues qui sont
venus me voir ou qui m'ont sollicité en
disant moi je veux faire la même chose
et donc je crois je crois vraiment que
l'exercice qu'on mène là est un exercice
vertueux
prêt concernant le et mégots et les
mégots ce qui me plaît et déchets bio
tabasser c'est une plaie c'est la raison
pour laquelle avant même d'entrer en
vigueur nous de
l'interdiction de fumer sur ces lieux là
on a on s'est attaché à ce que la ville
puisse être équipé du mobilier urbain
nécessaire ces mobiliers qui nous
évitera je l'espère de retrouver à
l'entrée de ces zones là à la frontière
de ces zones-là des amas de mégots un
peu partout sur la voie publique
monsieur vrai ce que vous aussi vous
sensibiliser à l'aspect environnemental
à la ligue contre le cancer ou c'est
vraiment l'aspect santé liés au tabac
qui n'ont particulièrement pour cette
cette mise en oeuvre si j'ose dire on a
effectivement on n'assiste pas trop sur
le côté pollution l'environnement c'est
dans les espaces publics ouverts c'est
pas ce qui est le plus prégnant c'est
véritablement on la trouvait
effectivement comme le dit monsieur on
la trouvait parmi les maires des des
gens qui étaient tout à fait porter à
aller dans ce sens ça pourquoi parce que
justement la présence de mégots et
quelque chose de considérable un nouveau
mais des années avant de ceux de
disparaître ils polluent énormément bien
plus qu'on ne le pense et peut-être même
bien plus que la fumée qu'il a dégagé
auparavant
merci à tous les deux
pour cette émission c'est la fin donc de
cette fuite société merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro est
bien sûr prenez soin de vous
je
[Musique]
tous